Hello. My name is Lee Young-soo, who is in charge of the second generation because of ferricana chicken.
Scrap 821 The 1st store in Ando is out. 2 Mr. Daun and Korea have
become very economical.
There is no fast food in Korea
.
2 base healthy and dot 0 1 year of movement This is the paper I bought for school
5 kilos Go or communicate with my parents now 2 1 photo 3 times 4 times a year
m1 colony
King Pride result of cute food I'm from the US too.  This is the way of
life, that is, Hunt 6, how it's salt and pepper, ginger, black pepper,
etc. The knife is water, but put it in a net for 12 hours. It's seasoned. The
salty liver and stomach. After two hours and no school, first  Yo,
we have a set time, and we went into the fryer. In 12 minutes and 1 hour, the
temperature of 350 degrees has subsided, so I'm talking to some extent that I kept this 62. It has
to come up a little while falling out.
It's just brown brown, so I used a darker color and
didn't dig out 62. My wife was super moist and I used it, but I
made the sauce a little different from others. I made the sauce a little different from others
.
When I mixed it and tried it, it came out to keep Yangyang, and there is even a Korean-made loader
through it, and
there is a method of rubbing the seasoning. Second, there is a method
of rubbing the chicken using the crushing agent, and the third is the seasoning of the
two.  Ah,
when I saw this Korean cp clock, it was 6 chicken Oh, it matches very well and the flow is
more frequent when I eat it I take it with me
Let it absorb the skin
.
Yes, and now, if I have to do a few days, mx will go a little further, so I added a smash.
I can do this, but I have to match the formula and give it to the nuns without paying the nuns.
First,
I should have done it because I ate it every week while watching people
’s sports broadcasts while watching sports broadcasts.
Celebrities in Celebrities are given the power of the land, such lives are inflicted on them
, and while watching the drama in China, prepare it quickly and become a craze.